[Musica]
albert hall
amava dire che quando un problema sembra
insolubile è perché lo stiamo
affrontando con le premesse sbagliate
oggi nella scienza c'è un problema che
difficilissimo è così difficile che ha
soprannominato l'art problem per
antonomasia questo problema non è un
problema che riguarda l'origine
dell'universo è un problema che riguarda
noi stessi che cosa siamo dove siamo nel
mondo fisico noi dove ci troviamo
le neuroscienze negli ultimi 100 anni si
sono concentrate soprattutto sulla sul
corpo sul cervello hanno cercato la cosa
che noi siamo dentro il nostro sistema
nervoso
eppure 150 anni di ricerche delle
neuroscienze finora non hanno trovato
niente che assomigli alla nostra
esperienza dentro il sistema nervoso
nessuno anche con le tecniche più
sofisticate di brain imaging oggi a
disposizione ha mai trovato dentro il
nostro cervello
qualcosa di simile alla nostra
esperienza
e allora come diceva einstein forse
dobbiamo mettere in discussione le
premesse sulle quali abbiamo passato
anni e anni di ricerca scientifica sulla
coscienza
forse la coscienza la nostra esperienza
fenomenica i colori che vediamo i sapori
che proviamo non si trovano dentro il
cervello ma dove si possono trovare io
vi chiedo di prendere in mano quella
mela che avete trovato sulla vostra
sedia e di guardarla di toccarla in
questo momento voi fate state facendo
esperienza di questo oggetto questa cosa
così semplice in realtà è un mistero per
la scienza perché ciò che voi trovate
nella vostra esperienza
nessun neuroscienziato
è riuscito a trovarlo dentro questo
oggetto meraviglioso che il cervello e
oggi le neuroscienze non sanno
rispondere a questa domanda come il
cervello possa creare al suo interno
questa cosa che la vostra esperienza
della mela
e allora io mi propongo di prendere in
considerazione un'ipotesi radicale che
all'inizio vi potrebbe apparire bizzarra
ma forse non è così strana come sembra
in questo momento
voi state toccando la mela e la vedete
e se io vi chiedessi descrive temi cosa
trovate nella vostra esperienza della
mela voi mi direte
io faccio esperienza e nella mia
esperienza c'è rosso c'è lucido si è
rotondo c'è la struttura della mela non
c'è niente del genere dentro il cervello
e l'ora ecco l'ipotesi che prendiamo in
considerazione oggi e se la cosa che è
la nostra esperienza della mela fosse la
mela stessa e se noi fossimo
letteralmente fuori del nostro corpo
e se questo oggetto che teniamo in mano
in questo momento fosse la base fisica
la cosa che è identica con noi stessi se
voi ci pensa te questa ipotesi
semplifica moltissimo la domanda su dove
siamo e cosa siamo
siamo un mondo siamo un oggetto non
siamo dietro gli occhi e mezza le
orecchie ma siamo davanti al nostro
corpo bene questa idea in realtà si
scontra con due obiezioni fondamentali
che sono il motivo per cui le
neuroscienze ha cercato dentro il
sistema nervoso
la nostra esperienza e le affronteremo
insieme
il primo problema da cui partiremo è la
cosiddetta variabilità soggettiva c'è il
fatto che questa mela può apparire
diversa
ciascuno di noi lamela può apparire di
un rosso vivace a me ma se qualcuno è
daltonico appare di un rosso molto meno
vivo può sembrare fredda si è tenuto
alle mani in un luogo caldo può sembrare
carta si è tenuto alle mani in una
bacinella gelata e per spiegare questa
variabilità della mela nel passato si è
ipotizzato che esistesse una mela e
tutti facessimo delle esperienze
soggettive che quindi andavano collocate
nella mente ma non è necessariamente
vero il mondo lamela e non la nostra
esperienza della mela ma lamela stessa è
molto più ricca di quanto non crediamo
prendiamo in considerazione una
proprietà semplice della mela la
velocità questa mela in questo momento è
ferma o si sta muovendo
questa mela ferma rispetto al
palcoscenico ma si sta muovendo rispetto
a degli oggetti che come un aereo come
una macchina che sono in movimento
rispetto a questa stanza quindi questa
mela per quanto può sembrare strano ed è
dal tempo di galileo che lo sappiamo è
sia in movimento sia ferma anzi questa
mela per quanto possa sembrare strano si
sta muovendo in tutte le direzioni
perché esistono infiniti oggetti che si
stanno muovendo le molecole dell'area i
pianeti gli aerei le macchine e quindi
questa mela ha infinite velocità anche
se noi ne possiamo vedere soltanto una
ma lo stesso ragionamento vale anche per
altre proprietà prendiamo il colore
guardate questa quadrato alle mie spalle
mi potrebbe sembrare più o meno bianco
come gli schermi dei calcolatori quando
vogliono produrre il bianco ma se voi vi
avvicinate voi vedrete che in realtà è
una griglia di puntini rossi verdi e blu
il cosiddetto bayern creed e bianca o è
una griglia di punti colorati e la
risposta che è bianca
relativamente a un corpo umano a più di
un metro di distanza ed è colorato
relativamente un corpo umano a pochi
centimetri di distanza oppure un corpo
diverso magari l'occhio di un'aquila che
è dotato di una risoluzione molto più
elevata e prendiamo in considerazione un
oggetto leggermente più complesso il
tremont
io vengo dalla liguria qui alle mie
spalle vedete la spiaggia di lavagna al
tramonto il tramonto è un oggetto che
esiste in modo diverso per ciascuno dei
corpi che si muovono sulla spiaggia è
infatti due persone in due posti diversi
fotograferanno 2 tramonti diversi e il
tramonto si sposta se noi ci spostiamo
il tramonto esiste relativamente al
nostro corpo è possibile estendere lo
stesso ragionamento per tutte le
proprietà della mela e mostrare che la
mela non esiste in assoluto ma lamela
esiste relativamente quindi l'idea
ingegno e da cui eravamo partiti secondo
cui di fronte alle diverse esperienze
della mela solo una è la vera mela
in realtà non è scientificamente
giustificata non è vero che esiste una
mela e tutte le altre sono esperienze
soggettive
esistono tante mail e quante le nostre
esperienze così come questa mela a tante
velocità quanti oggetti in movimento ci
sono in questa stanza a tanti colori
quanti sistemi interagiscono con lei
quindi in una frase noi non vediamo una
mela in cento modi diversi qui siamo in
centro ma vediamo 100 mele diverse
perché ognuna di queste mele esiste
relativamente a ciascuno dei vostri
corpi e questo risolverebbe il problema
della
variabilità della soggettività non è più
la soggettività a essere variabile ma il
mondo che è relativo e però dobbiamo
affrontare un altro problema molto grave
per questa ipotesi che vi ho presentato
quando noi facciamo esperienza della
mela e lamela annuncia come nel sogno o
nelle allucinazioni
non è la prova che quello che vediamo
non esiste nel mondo fisico ed è una
creazione del cervello
in realtà se noi guardiamo ai sogni e le
allucinazioni noi troveremo che sono
chimerici voi sapete la chimera era
fatta
era una creatura fantastica che era
costruita mettendo insieme tre animali
in maniera analoga i nostri sogni sono
una composizione della nostra vita
passata ma non contengono mai nessun
elemento radicalmente nuovo
avete mai sognato un colore che non
avete mai visto
avete mai sognato un componente
elementare una dimensione geometrica che
va oltre le nostre tre dimensioni
no i nostri sogni non creano ma
ricombinano sì però voi direte
va bene che i sogni ricombinano però la
mela quando dormo non c'è anche se la
sogna e allora e allora come suggerito
all'inizio da einstein
dobbiamo fare un passo indietro e
considerare anche il tempo cioè la
nostra idea ingenua di presente la mela
qui adesso è nel nostro presente
relativamente perché la mela è tra 15 e
300 millisecondi prima dell'attività nel
mio cervello perché la luce impiega
tempo da raggiungere la mia retina di
fotorecettori impiegano tempo e così via
e che dire della luna si trova a un
secondo virgola tra che è una mela un po
più lontana e dire del sole
e che dire delle costellazioni sì lo so
ci hanno sempre detto che le
costellazioni quando le vediamo
potrebbero non esistere più
perché la luce impiega la stella
potrebbe essere già esploso sempre
catastrofisti gli astronomi ma in realtà
anche lamela potrebbe non esistere più
quando la vediamo se uno la mangiasse
nei 300 millisecondi e i processi fisici
impiegano ad arrivare al nostro cervello
tutti questi esempi ci mostrano come il
nostro presente in realtà sia esteso nel
tempo
il nostro è presente non è un punto è
qualche cosa che si distribuisce in
un'estensione temporale
e questo non solo nella memoria nel
sogno ma anche nella percezione basta
uscire fuori sedersi su un prato a
guardare il sole guardare le stelle e il
nostro presente si estende per minuti
ore decine di anni e allora l'ipotesi
qual è l'ipotesi che nel sogno
noi siamo isolati da questo presente
prossimo e cominciamo a percepire in
combinazioni le più varie
il nostro passato la nostra vita che si
ripresenta noi in modo chimerico ma
senza aggiungere niente di radicalmente
nuovo
e da questo punto di vista quindi sogni
sarebbero una percezione del passato in
conclusione nella scacchiera spazio
temporale che è la casa della scienza
noi abbiamo due oggetti l'oggetto
esterno la mela e il corpo il cervello
quale di questi due oggetti è la cosa
che noi siamo le neuroscienze finora
hanno cercato senza trovarla
la nostra esperienza dentro il cervello
e se fosse l'oggetto esterno
e se fosse la mela
queste ipotesi ci permette di superare
i limiti dell'antropocentrismo che si
riflettono nell'idea che il centro della
nostra esistenza sia il nostro corpo è
ancora una forma di antropocentrismo
ancora l'idea che l'uomo rappresentate
idealmente da leonardo da vinci
dell'uomo vitruviano se al centro
dell'universo
invece forse la cosa che siamo non è il
nostro corpo ma è il mondo esterno
forse l'uomo non è al centro
dell'universo come darwin e copernico
hanno dimostrato in due importanti
occasioni forse al centro della realtà
c'è la realtà stessa che esiste
relativamente ai nostri corpi che la
fanno esistere in tanti modi diversi
non perché siano speciali ma perché
partecipano alla realtà quindi il
messaggio che voglio dare oggi perché
forse noi non siamo neuroni non siamo
informazione dentro al cervello ma noi
siamo mondo siamo nuvola siamo ce lo
siamo realtà grazie
[Applauso]